you are watching cole fusion tv
[Music]
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
there's a lot of buzz around artificial
intelligence at the moment and the term
ai seems to be thrown around a lot but
what is it exactly
to clear things up i just wanted to do a
quick video around this topic
first of all let's look at the
definition to avoid confusion we have to
go back to the earliest and hence purest
definition of ai from the time when it
was first coined
the official idea and definition of ai
was first coined by jay mccartney in
1955 at the dartmouth conference
of course there was plenty of research
work done on ai by others such as alan
turing before this but what they were
working on was an undefined field before
1955.
okay so here's what mccarthy proposed
quote
every aspect of learning or any other
feature of intelligence can in principle
be so precisely described that a machine
can be made to simulate it
an attempt will be made to find out how
to make machines use language form
abstractions and concepts solve kinds of
problems now reserve for humans and
improve themselves
translation
in essence ai is a machine with the
ability to solve problems that are
usually done by us humans with our
natural intelligence
a computer will demonstrate a form of
intelligence when it learns how to
improve itself at solving these problems
to elaborate further the 1955 proposal
defines seven areas of ai
today there's surely more but here are
the original seven
one simulating higher functions of the
human brain
two
programming a computer to use general
language
three
arranging hypothetical neurons in a
manner enabling them to form concepts
four
a way to determine and measure problem
complexity
five self-improvement
six abstraction defined as the quality
of dealing with ideas rather than events
7. randomness and creativity
after 60 years i think realistically
we've completed the language measure of
problem complexity and self-improvement
to at least some degree however
randomness and creativity is just
starting to be explored this year we've
seen a couple of web episode scripts
short films and even a feature length
film co-written or completely written by
ai they don't really make sense but
here's a few snippets for your
entertainment anyway
i need to leave
but i'm not free
of the world yes perhaps i should uh
take it from here
[Music]
i'm not gonna do something
it's not a dream
but i've got a time to stay there well i
still think you could be back on the
table
it's a damn thing scared to say
nothing
is going to be a thing
from not make is so longer of the face
in the comprised and a person is what
the world on the country of have the
construction of the mic could the person
in front are
and how they deal to part of them
okay so in the definition you heard the
word intelligence what is intelligence
well according to jack copeland who has
written several books on ai some of the
most important factors of intelligence
are
generalization learning that is learning
that enables the learner to be able to
perform better in situations not
previously encountered
reasoning
to reason is to draw conclusions
appropriate to the situation in hand
problem solving
given such and such data find x
perception
analyzing a scanned environment and
analyzing features and relationships
between objects self-driving cars are an
example
language understanding
understanding language by following
syntax and other rules similar to a
human
okay so now we have an understanding of
ai and intelligence to bring it together
a bit and solidify the concept in your
mind of what ai is here's a few examples
of ai
machine learning computer vision natural
language processing robotics pattern
recognition and knowledge management
there are also different types of
artificial intelligence in terms of
approach
for example there's strong ai and weak
ai
strong ai is simulating the human brain
by building systems that think and in
the process give us an insight into how
the brain works
we're nowhere near this stage yet
weak ai is a system that behaves like a
human but doesn't give us an insight
into how the brain works
ibm's deep blue a chess playing ai was
an example
it processed millions of moves before it
made any actual moves on the chessboard
it doesn't stop there though there's
actually a new kind of middle ground
between strong and weak ai
this is where a system is inspired by
human reasoning but doesn't have to
stick to it ibm's watson is an example
like humans it reads a lot of
information recognizes patterns and
builds up evidence to say hey i'm x
percent confident that this is the right
solution to the question that you have
asked me from the information that i've
read
if you want to know more in ibm watson
you can click on the annotation now or
the link in the description below
google's deep learning is similar as it
mimics the structure of the human brain
by using neural networks but doesn't
follow its function exactly the system
uses nodes that act as artificial
neurons connecting information
going a little bit deeper neural
networks are actually a subset of
machine learning
so what's machine learning then machine
learning refers to algorithms that
enable software to improve its
performance over time as it obtains more
data
this is programming by input output
examples rather than just coding
so that this makes more sense let's use
an example
a programmer would have no idea how to
program a computer to recognize a dog
but he can create a program with a form
of intelligence that can learn to do so
if he gives the program enough image
data in the form of dogs and let it
process and learn when you give the
program an image of a new dog that it's
never seen before it would be able to
tell that it's a dog with relative ease
okay so before we finish just one last
concept
most artificial intelligence algorithms
are expert systems
so what's an expert system
the often cited definition of an expert
system is as follows
an expert system is a system that
employs human knowledge in a computer to
solve problems that ordinarily require
human expertise
basically it's the practical application
of a knowledge database
we've arguably only just got the first
proven non-expert system this year
deepmind's alphago alphago is not an
expert system meaning that its
algorithms could be used and applied to
other things
demus hasibus who was the co-creator of
deepmind highlighted this in a google
blog
quote
we are thrilled to have mastered go and
thus achieved one of the grand
challenges of ai however the most
significant aspect of all of this for us
is that alphago isn't just an expert
system built on handcrafted rules
instead it uses general machine learning
techniques to figure out for itself how
to win go
he goes on
quote because the methods we've used a
general purpose our hope is that one day
they could be extended to help us
address some of society's toughest and
most pressing problems from climate
modelling to complex disease analysis
end quote
in other words the algorithms that
alphago use to win go could serve as a
basis to be applied to very complex
problems
if you want to know more about alphago
hit the annotation now or you can follow
the link in the description
alright so to bring this all together
and summarize all that we've learnt
let's recap
so what is ai
commonly ai or artificial intelligence
is a machine or a computer program that
learns how to do tasks that require
forms of intelligence and are usually
done by humans
and the other thing to take away
intelligence comes in many forms and has
many different aspects
at this time we just have many different
types of ais that are good at particular
subsets of intelligence
so anyway i hope that clears things up
as a lot of people were confused about
what ai actually is
so anyway thanks for watching give this
video a thumbs up if you liked it and
subscribe if you're new to the channel
cheers guys this has been to go go
you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
video have a good one
cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]